so why hasn't President Obama already
closed Guantanamo I put that question to
Elizabeth beavers she's a security and
human rights advocate at Amnesty
International USA in Washington well
thank you very much for having me and
for covering this really important
development there's been a number of
factors that have prevented Guantanamo
closure from home from over the years
one is a lack of political will from the
Obama administration a closing
Guantanamo is going to take big bold
steps concrete steps towards closure
thankfully this latest transfer shows
that perhaps they do indeed have the
political will to follow through on this
promise to do the right thing and to
close the detention camp but so far they
just haven't exerted that will there are
also a misinformation and false
information fear-mongering that has
crept up in the conversation about
Guantanamo the US public and many
members of the US Congress mistakenly
and don't quite understand exactly who
is at Guantanamo and exactly why it must
be closed and unfortunately that is a
very loud voice it's a very loud
presence in the debate but we still
believe at Amnesty International there
is time if we have the public pressure
and the political will gordana mo can be
closed okay so here's the thing and it
these people many of most of these
people have not been charged they
certainly haven't been tried so if
you're going to ship them out why not
send them back where you got them from
sure you know that the there's a lot of
layers to your question there you're
exactly right there are only 10 people
in Guantanamo who have either been
charged or going through the trial
system that's been set up the Military
Commission system the rest of them are
not facing trial the vast majority are
not even facing charge so you know many
of these individuals were taken from
many different parts of the world
unfortunately some of them are not able
to return to their home countries
because there are security situations or
because they may face human rights
abuses in their home country so many
those who have been transferred must be
resettled elsewhere once detainees are
released from Guantanamo we just heard
about these going back to they got being
sent to the United Arab Emirates having
been released are they free well there's
a lot of diplomatic procedures that goes
into each transfer and there are
agreements that are made separately with
each country that is receiving detainees
at this point we're still collecting
information about these 15 individuals
we have not yet received information
that they are to be further detained but
we're still monitoring the situation you
know it's important to know it's not
enough to just close Guantanamo by
sending people away they must be sent
somewhere safely where their human
rights will be protected